détruire des choses étranges donc c'est
un bon le dérangeait pas je vais vous la
ramenez cette liste m non j'y vais merci
une résidence pour mettre en scène leur
spectacle les voyageurs du crime
comédien et metteur en scène étaient
présents théâtre de la celle saint cloud
au mois de septembre
objectif travailler l'aspect artistique
et technique vraiment très de de
coordination etc
c'est pour ça que les résidences sont
très importantes et que c'est de très
belles opportunités que nous offre les
villes ça permet vraiment d'avancé sur
un travail qui est très lourd et seront
très compliqués à faire au dernier
moment et l avantage une résidence et
que ça offre quelques jours voire une
semaine ou dix jours comme l'a par
exemple à la celle saint cloud où on
peut travailler aisément leur passage au
théâtre de la celle-saint-cloud aura
duré une dizaine de jours
l'occasion de faire un premier filage et
de s'attarder sur les détails pour la
première fois on va faire ce qu'on
appelle le boutabout le premier filage
pour voir avec toute la mise en scène
qu'on a calé cette semaine on essaye les
costumes pour voir s'il ya des soucis et
puis on essaye un petit peu avec des
accessoires aussi qu'on a pour se
dépatouiller un peu tout voir comment
est-ce qu'on pose les choses des
chapeaux les manteaux les voilà c'est
une première premiers débuts de travail
c'est important pour nous et
de l'appartement mais ma mère l'était
plus la faire le spectacle et la suite
du cercle de whitechapel
les personnages se retrouvent quelques
années après dans l'orient-express est
là
conan doyle est plus connu qu'une disant
forcément auparavant il a écrit beaucoup
beaucoup de succès et les plus établies
voilà bon il est veuf et donc ses amis
ont décidé de l'emmener dans un long
voyage afin de lui changer les idées
sauf que dans ce voyage il va se passer
beaucoup de choses assez étrange une
disparition voilà ce qui attend les
personnages du spectacle une équipe
composée de personnages ayant existé va
se mettre à enquêter à savoir bram
stocker qui était l'auteur de dracula
arthur conan doyle l'auteur de sherlock
holmes et george bernard shaw qui était
un journaliste mais également auteur de
théâtre une représentation du spectacle
les voyageurs du crime aura lieu au
théâtre de la celle saint cloud en avril